martine laroche-joubert notre envoyé
spécial est allé à gaza à la rencontre
des enfants ce sont eux qui payent le
plus cher cette révolte des pierres
reportage un taxi collectif palestiniens
c'est le meilleur moyen pour nous de
pénétrer en ce moment à gaza
d'abord parce que les palestiniens
jettent des pierres sur les voitures
immatriculées en israël ensuite parce
que les israéliens qui n'interdisent pas
ce jour-là de fumer à gaza redoutent que
la présence de caméras de reportage
provins des manifestations nous partons
donc avec une vidéo 8 de touristes c'est
une question pratique
il vient d'abord à l'esprit comment
peuvent-ils au quotidien après onze mois
de soulèvement tarral tient une épicerie
la plupart des produits sont fabriqués
dans les territoires occupés ici le
label made in gaza a une signification
politique
le boycott des produits israéliens
au sein des familles leur force vient du
fait même que d'une scie pas dans le
soulèvement palestinien est devenu leur
mode de vie à eux et cela suit pour les
adultes comme pour les enfants
la situation est si mauvaise que nous
sommes prêts à nous sacrifier nous mêmes
et nos enfants nous n'avons rien à
perdre si l'intifada ne marche pas eh
bien nous pouvons mourir je fais
l'intifada j lancé des pierres sur les
soldats mais d' outils les a jetés de ma
porte
je vise les faits je veux la paix
les juifs nous tirent dessus j'ai peur
des soldats plus tard je veux être
docteur
allingham meneur est plus important que
le sang qui coule et le cri du
soulèvement plus fort que celui de
l'occupation
aujourd'hui elles vont toutes deux en
classe les lycée de garçons sont fermées
par l'armée après tous ces mois passés
dans les rues des pierres à la main ils
attendent eux aussi cette semaine les
décisions du conseil national
palestinien à alger
linden nous voulons qu'ils fondent un
état palestinien avec une armée
palestinienne pour me protéger et
imposer nos droits face aux israéliens
c'est nous mourrons pour notre pays nous
sommes d'accord mais comment tu
t'appelles abou ammar le nom de guerre
de yasser arafat le chef mythique mais
si lointain aujourd'hui ils attendent de
lui un geste qui briserait enfin leur
sensation d'isolement